who doesn't like the fake lips let's
just be honest
the fake lips work right i don't like
them women like when we have fake hair
they like when we're on finasteride and
our hair is maintained so we like that
i'm sure there's been fake lips that are
well done that i didn't notice and i'm
like oh that looks good yeah when they
look all pillowy and [ __ ] i'm like oh i
can't do but it's better than if you
look like a bird
[Laughter]
isn't it better than that yeah
right so i think that's what we have to
judge we have to judge like not what's
better if you have perfect lips versus
plastic surgery it's like everybody
looking like madonna right now she kind
of looks like the alien uh her face but
like alien workshop remember them
skateboarding people have that that's
literally on his face she looks like
that but is that better than what she
would naturally look like being 70 years
old
yeah no no
but if you were to make love to a
seven-year-old woman would you want her
to be like 70
no that's what i'm saying she aged out
of being made love to yeah i i know your
point what i'm saying is in this
hypothetical scenario where you have to
make love to a seven-year-old wouldn't
you want her to just shove [ __ ] in her
face until
you saw you saw the video you know what
i mean i mean it's horrifying dude but
but but but okay go to uh titanic and
the old woman in titanic she's 70. for
70 that's good the old woman in titanic
is 70 years old
that throws the thing old rose old rose
is seven years old which one are you
taking 70 72 maybe
i don't know if that's that's three
years old
seven years old how do you know that
40 years ago
there's a whole thing about it and i'm
going to come back here when i'm 72.
and then return the heart of the ocean
to the ocean or whatever i think you
made all this i'm not making you know
112 years old objectively
you don't think that she looks better
objectively speaking go back to titanic
go to titanic i'm going to tell you i'm
going to give you an honest answer yeah
honest answer it's not even a debate bro
it's not a debate come on no madonna
debate i think i agree with you
look at that right that's seven years
old all not [ __ ] rose for sure no you
you're you're you're lying to me which
crevice be honest no i'm going madonna
of course if you're doing you're a
weirdo dog
i mean it's not even a question
you're also madonna just for legacy too
yeah just like the biggest pop star of
all time
yeah yeah i want the cone tits and
everything yeah i want the full
experience
yeah
that's [ __ ] great
but also speaking of people aging this
[ __ ] was going viral this is a buddhist
monk he's like 108 year old buddhist
monk oh come on don't do this [ __ ] bro
yo this guy looked like madonna yeah oh
my god stop playing still alive stop
playing and like he's just living his
best life doing his thing let him die
doc that's crazy like at a certain point
have you thought about this like you're
going to get to a point where you're
going to be dumb old you're going to be
on all the machines that's not real fam
it's real he's only 108.
oh my god only yeah but you shouldn't
look like that at
you look like king tut right now
same do same
yeah no that's crazy but have you
thought about this like yo when i get to
a certain point call it
no no no yeah cause we don't know where
technology is gonna be but if i start
looking like that call it what do you
mean looking like
is it the look or is it like your
ability to walk around and do that's the
look yo i don't want to look like that
okay you call me vayne if you want to i
don't want to look like that even if
you're still capable you could douche it
you're like no just not the way he looks
like a smoker's
all he is just along all he needs some
lip colors he'll be good yeah exactly
that's it facts good but no i mean this
is picky what is what is he first of all
like what what why was he before this
like what race like i don't even know
what he is he's tired probably yeah he's
thai
yeah
oh my god let the baby go he's sucking
the life force out of he's trying to get
her youth i mean this is no al you
didn't see this yeah i'm just it's
insane right wow
yeah i mean this is just so no this is
prosthetics or something like that i
don't believe this is real that's not
real oh the robot right it has to be a
robot there's some april fools [ __ ]
right this is [ __ ] when did it come
out this is april fools this is like
february 22nd
there's music there's no no no no no no
no no no there's no way it's real dude
look at the eye sockets
yeah he's old yeah but don't you think
they'd be more like squinted oh my god
maybe after 100 they start getting
bigger that's the tipping point
but have you thought about this like
having like a do not resuscitate once
you're like 105 no i want to run it i
want to run it even if you're really
huh you're in a coma
yeah
i think i come back from that okay i
think i would come back from a coma
fully incapacitated in a coma you're 105
years old dude imagine how terrifying
that is you're in the coma you could
hear everything still but you just can't
communicate and they're deciding whether
to pull the plug or not that's the thing
what that happens to a lot of people
they're like oh yeah i'm so glad you
didn't like pull the plug they remember
everything yeah like i could hear you
the whole time
yeah
and then like one person like one parent
was like yeah let's just you know
and then the other parents like no we
gotta keep him around
and then he wakes up like pisses [ __ ] at
his dad for trying
that's the thing that's actually
happened i've seen that
there's a video of this i mean i don't
know if there's a video like i need to
see this person i don't think they're
just filming the kid like let's kill him
i mean why not
you're not trying to make content yeah
that's a good point but we should have
that we should have one of these people
on the podcast yeah i would love to know
what they do someone in a coma yeah
they kind of just laid it down yeah
they're mostly lying but how do you feel
that's what they do physically [ __ ]
how do you pass through the day like
you're aware you have your thoughts you
can hear everything going on you just
can't communicate so you're just taking
in everything and just thinking all day
yeah jesus